the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video all
right my friends in this video we will
be looking at all of the new exclusive
photos that were released with
entertainment weekly's massive cover
story in the video i uploaded yesterday
i read some of the interesting
information from that article now i want
to actually go through those new photos
one by one everything that we do see in
the new photos will also be seen during
the first season of house of the dragon
they do give us some idea of what we
should see
now let's begin in the first photo we
can see the great sir harold westerling
who is a knight from house westerling as
well as the lore commander of the
kingsguard under king viserys targaryen
we should see him standing by the
sarah's targaryen side during most of
the first season he will be the lord
commander of the kingsguard for nearly a
decade until his death in the year of
112 ac after he dies sir kristin cole
will become the next lore commander of
the kingsguard now in the next photo we
see serato hightower and his daughter
alicent as you can see this is when they
are using the younger actress for alice
sent so this should be from a scene at
the beginning of the first season
cerrado was also a knight from his house
who goes on to become the hand of the
king for three different kings serado
hightower first becomes the hand of the
king to jiharis targaryen who is seated
on the iron throne just before viserys
now after the death of king jiharis
sarado will then go on to become the
hand of the king for viserys targaryen
as well he will be one of the men who
actually encourages vasaris to name his
daughter rhaenyra as his heir for the
iron throne one of the reasons serrato
does this is because of his hatred for
the king's brother daemon targaryen
serado and daemon will be bitter rivals
during the course of house of the dragon
something i'm very interested in seeing
unfold on the screen
now his daughter alicent will go on to
marry king viserys targaryen after the
death of his wife and newborn son
the marriage of asaris and alicent will
eventually lead to them having sons of
their own in the next photo you can see
that alicent and rhaenyra were once
friends they actually look very happy in
the photo but this will eventually come
to an end once alice sent and her son
begin fighting rhaenara and daemon for
the rights over the iron throne
now if you look right behind rhaenyra
and alicent you will see that there is a
massive werewood
something we would normally see north of
king's landing now there is a godswood
in king's landing but that heartwood is
not a weirwood the tree that is in the
godswood of king's landing is made of
oak i think this scene might actually be
in harrenhal or somewhere else we know
they will be at several different
locations during the first season in the
next photo we can see their relationship
beginning to go up in flames the photo
shows rhaenyra and alicent when they're
a little older most likely later in the
season now if you look over allison's
shoulder you can see someone standing
there with what looks like a fresh
injury to their eye that is king viserys
saying allison's son aemond onei who as
you can see had just lost his eye
that is in thanks to rhaenyra's son
lucari's velaryon this little fight
happened because amon was making fun of
rhaenyra's sons he said they were
actually fathered by a member of hal
strong which would obviously make them
bastards well as you can imagine her son
luceries did not like that whatsoever so
he slashed at amon's face with a dagger
removing one of his eyes
alicent understandably becomes furious
and she begins demanding an eye for an
eye in other photos we see her running
with the valyrian steel dagger in hand
it's the same valyrian steel dagger we
have seen with her husband viserys
targaryen it's also the same dagger we
would later see in game of thrones the
one that was used during bran's
attempted assassination as well as when
arya defeated the night king now during
this scene alison does not get what she
wants she does not get her eye for an
eye however later on aemon will
eventually get his revenge
something i know i'm definitely looking
forward to seeing unfold on our screens
as well the next photo shows daemon
targaryen holding a dragon egg this is
most likely when he steals a dragon egg
to give to his mistress massaria he does
this because masaria was going to have
his baby however once king viserys finds
out daemon gave her the egg he not only
demands that he gets it back but he also
wants damon to get rid of massaria by
sending her away we have seen some more
evidence of this in the teaser trailers
in one scene you can see daemon sneaking
around the dragon's den
in fact i would bet the dragon wasn't
very happy he was snatching the egg if
you look at daemon's face in the new
photo you can see there is black smoke
and sweat all over it i think he might
have had a little bit of a hard time
getting the egg without the dragon
reacting in some way now he does get it
however but he won't have it for long
it looks like viserys will send serato
to dragonstone to get the egg from
daemon while also letting him know that
massaria is no longer welcome in the
city this should be a very interesting
discussion as well considering daemon
and serato already hate each other i bet
this won't go over well either
in the next photo we have rhaenyra
targaryen standing in front of her
father viserys targaryen at the foot of
the iron throne this should be after
viserys had named his daughter the heir
for the iron throne when the lords and
ladies of westeros come to swear they're
fealty now after viserys dies some of
these men who swore fealty will no
longer want to stand beside raenara's
side instead they will fight for alicent
and her son aegon the new king
which will lead to even more issues
among the blacks and the greens
someone rhaenara will be able to depend
on is who we see next in the new photo
here we have lorcorlus velaryon and his
wife rhaenys targaryen they will fight
for the sight of rhaenyra and daemon not
only does rhaenyra have children with
one of their sons but daemon has
children with one of their daughters as
well they have more than enough reasons
to want to see their side not only
survive but ultimately win in the next
photo we get this really great shot of
daemon targaryen dressed head to toe in
his armor which i must say does look
incredible i absolutely love that helmet
that has the dragon and its red eyes
with its massive wings coming off its
back it also looks like daemon has red
rubies on his chest something rhaegar
targaryen had on his armor as well
another one of the new photos shows
daemon fighting sir kristen cole sir
kristen cole will actually win this
fight by knocking aside daemon's
valyrian steel sword dark sister with
his morning star
afterwards sir kristen will give the
victors loyal to the 7 year old rhaenyra
targaryen and last but certainly not
least we have this new photo we should
actually see this in the very first
episode of the show
seated right at the center is king
jaharis targaryen who is having trouble
deciding on who will be his heir for the
iron throne after his original heirs
have died
now in order for him to settle the
matter he decides to have a great
council at the castle of harrenhal
during 101 ac
during that great council they will vote
for who will take the iron throne after
jiharis is gone
the number one man who is in a running
is viserys targaryen who is standing at
his left next to his wife emma aaron as
you can see his wife is visibly pregnant
with his child unfortunately she will
eventually lose their son as well as her
own life due to complications from the
child birth now standing at the right of
jiharis is lord corliss velaryon and his
wife rainey targaryen she was actually
in the running for the iron throne
herself but since she was a woman she
eventually gets set aside for another
man
now there were several men who wanted
the iron throne but there were really
only two major candidates who were
considered that is viserys targaryen and
the young lenore velaryon son of
lorcorlus valerion and rainey's
targaryen now for a number of different
reasons viserys will win by a landslide
setting him as next in line for the iron
throne
after seeing all the new photos it looks
like we're about to be in for one hell
of a show i know i'm very excited and i
hope all of you are too as always i will
be here making videos if anything else
is released or announced now that we're
only about a month away we should be
getting even more official photos and
videos from hbo make sure you subscribe
so you can stay up to date on any and
everything regarding game of thrones and
house of the dragon i want to thank all
of you for watching another one of my
videos i honestly cannot thank all of
you enough for all the love you've been
showing it really does mean a lot i hope
you're all back here for my next video i
will see you again very soon
bye
hmm
[Music]
you